taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz and we got a guest today
Mr Ricky geez no I didn't I just took it
the phenomenal yeah it's a pleasure to
be here yeah the uh does anybody call
you the ass man like Seinfeld style not
not they never no one's ever called me
that a second time
oh someone's got a cough it looks like
it's working
we're happy to have you here we're
battling childhood versus adulthood
today we all yes and you've chosen to be
I like when guests choose to be the
moderator kind of in the middle of the
argument yeah uh but but we'll get to
that maybe I mean you're like a teen
right you're a child and adult at the
same exact time right now yeah maybe tea
should argue teen yeah you know I just
have fun if we put the poll out like
that right yeah yeah that's fine I think
it's just important that we recognize
that all of us are still children even
the adults and I feel like they're not
mutually exclusive and there's Arguments
for either side and as a fan I'm just
looking forward to hearing and I'm
grateful that I get an opportunity to
have a little bit of a say in it but why
don't you guys get started sure sure
what uh what brings you want to jump
right into it babe or you just want to
kind of I was just gonna ask
um I uh I came in from Los Angeles to
visit my girlfriend thank you very much
and uh he didn't say fluent he said I
just came in we get it is your penis
tired yeah there you go
um edit that out
that's my personal life
is it though I just came into New York
all over the Internet yeah but not with
my girl well no no but he was saying you
used your to get here no he was making a
he was making a joke because I was with
my girlfriend
why don't you tell me what the joke
right you prostituted yourself across
this country
came into New York and where'd you come
from
Los Angeles right but where do you come
from where do you ejaculate from oh I
don't like this okay okay yes well you
ejaculate from your penis
you know this you ejaculate out of your
penis you ejaculate from your prostate
and balls okay fair oh wow so you said
it's a good yeah I came out of it I just
you didn't say you just flew in and the
the so so so so the planet just came
from it's right right yeah and my arms
are tired it just came in I worked out
this morning it was penis penis penis I
just came in from somewhere so you came
in something you came in and that's what
I'm saying is my personal life right no
it's not though what do you think I came
in uh uh a manila envelope no no no you
said
you came from
no I came in I just came into New York
yes and that's why you said you can't
you can't and boy is your penis time New
York is what you came in now I oh yes
yes
I know I know I know absolutely and I'm
saying I have seen your penis yes and
I'm saying I think people thought you
were joking and now get it fine put it
out there where can people say this is
not uh fappening is that a thing you
were all over the fapping I don't know
what that reference it was you Jennifer
Lawrence it was one of those celebrity
nude sleeps I remember it was called the
fappening yeah and that and then there
was something about something that on
Jennifer Lawrence on her back well I
don't want to talk about my personal
life oh snap
Oh that's oh Rick last penis and a
picture of Pete Holmes and big J come up
for some reason
that's very weird uh Bobby Lee there's
Bobby Lee there's Bobby Lee's podcast
at this point I don't know what is this
you search you Rick lesson's penis yeah
these are the pictures that come up do
you guys normally do this with guests
this is I'm a professional dramatic
actor yeah so we usually Bing
Chandler
yes
we argued Chandler uh we argued friends
versus Seinfeld on here could that have
been a better episode
[Music]
one but not by you guys are such good
friends
[Music]
that's great I wish I had one I got
nothing I'll watch you pivot onto
something different
like your penis did you mean that did
you pivot on it buddy you did okay uh
you think I did a few things without
intention he's an idiot what was pivot
pivot was from friends oh well when
they're going up the stair moving a
couch yeah I gotta tell you something oh
yeah I remember that episode that's a
funny you guys probably did a friends
verse Seinfeld right yeah yeah yeah
Chuck Seinfeld I did yeah so you you
lost right I took friends because I had
just started watching friends you don't
even know the pivot you took friends I
know that episode now I just here's um
well I was about to he was on he was on
a friend's kick it was on a friend's
kick I just started watching it this
year
and I was really loving it right and I
was like I'll defend friends because
that is the fair rival for Seinfeld and
uh and I I was like I'll defend it and I
got to tell you right after that I hit
about mid-season three and boy do I hate
all right I'm just tired yeah Venus yeah
I hate it after like it hits like a
midpoint in season three and I was like
God all this is now is like this back
and forth whining about like their
relationships it's not fun anymore it
was so much more fun when they were
disagree I thought it was kind of shine
around three yeah I thought it was great
I thought maybe toward the end but I
don't think you could do friends or
Seinfeld because
people there's no way you're gonna turn
anybody those friends people in the
Seinfeld too I feel like you could do a
Seinfeld verse curb
we wanted to we thought about that do it
but no I thought it was I thought the
arguments were too similar I thought the
programs were too similar and so I was
like
I would like to
to have a little more diversity in the
argument well it's funny because it's
all a bunch of white people I know yeah
I know that's what I say at least at
least curb has you know the the black
family I know well no I mean uh George
did uh Watch Breakfast at Tiffany's with
a black family that is true it's an
episode not uh well they came back in
another episode they do and boy is this
tired
the round she maybe it's four maybe it's
season four I don't know but somewhere
in there when they started going hard on
like uh A-list celebrity guests
constantly yeah that is not that far in
and like and then it just gets like when
Phoebe starts like looking for her
brother and her family and like
shiovanni were basic yeah and it just
starts it just starts to become about
like what's going on with with Ross and
Rachel and like like yeah I don't know
it's just like it's a big one it's a
nuclear you know a lot of people have
some problems that weddings when I go
I'm done and um what happened when Bruce
Willis the actor was in it and their uh
Chandler and Joey's favorite movie is
Die Hard was established before then and
they were never able to reference it you
know at least in at least in Last Action
Hero when they go into Blockbuster
Sylvester Stallone is Terminator you
know they make uh is that is that real
yeah they allow is that true yeah no
yeah yeah they put Arnold he's not
because Arnold Schwarzenegger they made
that joke yeah when they're in the movie
World Arnold Schwarzenegger is the actor
but he isn't the actor or the character
in that it's a different person so in
the world where these movies exist
Terminator 2 couldn't be played by
understood but they went that far so
there's a poster of cardboard cutout of
Stallone in the leather jacket very
funny when the kids in the movie
of the movie where Schwarzenegger I
fully have understood from the beginning
uh do you though yeah I'm just saying
wow I can't believe they actually went
there and made the joke yeah yeah and
Last Action here it was a great movie
yeah you know what I watched again and
it didn't hold up the running man oh I
love the running man you're not have you
watched it recently yes have you danced
at any time in the past five years
what's that no yeah well that's a fell
out of favor
people do the Running Man well Tick Tock
does have 70 billion people on it so we
might find it uh were you about to
disagree with me though that friends you
like that period of friends I was never
what is it called a friend's head yeah I
was never a friend's head but like I
still understand and respect it
I just do do you pilot the friendship
um I've been on it I never drove it um I
wouldn't pay the lease it see you can
see I've seen many many seasons I've
seen most of the episodes and it's just
a great show throughout it's it you I
disagree but you can see you can see but
that's what I'm here to do this thing
you can see the movie like the moniker
the Rachel Ross when uh when when um
there's a thing I don't like when Rachel
stops being a screw-up and gets like a
real job and like becomes responsible I
just don't think it's interesting but uh
Rob mcelhenney said when he got fat for
that season if it's always sunny he said
the reason he did that because he goes
you watch these popular sitcoms and they
just get better looking literally
friends is the prime example you can see
the episode from one to the next in
season four where they become rich and
they're like you're like it's just not
the same anymore I'm watching rich
people pretend to be struggling in New
York now Seinfeld got a tit job
who Seinfeld Jerry yeah you made a movie
out of it be a movie oh b cup movie you
should have said you should have said
before Oh I like that you didn't say cup
because Stanley Kubrick says it's more
interesting if the audience gets to make
the discovery instead of showing it to
them and when you said I was thinking
because you already did you made a
connection yeah yeah he never said that
by the way
yes he did Kubrick
oh you wanna argue I was highly proven
that people you guys it's Kubrick if
you've seen the Brian the teens the
audition tape which we watched on on hey
babe and it kind of fell flat it's been
it's been proven over and over that
that's a missed quote I believe that uh
I still I I made that assumption uh
beforehand I mean I don't know why it
wouldn't be really I just made up that I
just was doing it I was trying to do the
thing you do you guys are out doing the
attention he's doing gonna do it back to
you you know what you're saying is it
possible but I don't I don't subscribe
to that was it misnomer what is it
misnomer Mr gnomer's wife okay okay
no they got divorced okay that was very
cool and she kept his name well their
name that was very quick pronouns what
you just did that's one of my things
I've grabbed chocolate out of his hand
you didn't even see it coming yeah we'll
cut to a clip I'll send it to you
no you're like he's Lightning Fast
really on the courts and off I know no
no no no he's he's very quick and you
did it a lot when I was in other
sentences
laughs
when I was on your podcast and it was I
mean yeah
the sleepover Series yeah it was fun did
you have oakerson on is that why he came
out I have had him on okay that's right
out of his penis ah
forgot to see it's running down my pants
I could already see the comments I'm
talking too much I'm getting excited
playing with friends do your thing
that's not that's not that's not that's
not that's not this that's not what's
Happening Here where they're all in
whatever what happens happens that you
know that that's not true you know that
these these fans don't really care for
you
but let me tell you something if you say
it and you get them in the mentality
that No No One's Gonna complain that
you're you're funny we're having a great
Convoy I'm having a great time but I
also be like children and that's fun
so I make myself at home in a way that
I'm I love and I love when it's done and
I love receiving it yeah but it could be
threatening to people coming in who is
this guy coming in they're supposed to
talk about adults and kids and now
they're talking about die hard yeah okay
and the running man that's true and uh
this is what happens so we go all over
and then we kind of will focus up again
soon well I wanted to acknowledge it and
I want to say thank you for having me
and this is great being here the running
man might be a good like think of all
the Macarena the this The Running Man
the Cabbage Patch that could be a good
battle there could be lighting there's
only one dance battle moonwalk no no no
no well I mean if there was one it's
moonwalk so there's two right there's
only one major dance battle and it's
Macarena versus the electric slide and
you know it that's the battle I think
the real battle is the moonwalk was the
original Electric Slide
you
there's a
there's a Cha-Cha Slide if nobody knows
I don't even know what that is well it's
very similar to the electric one yeah
you could do
mooc versus another
magic trick the moonwalk is the Michael
Jackson of dances
University Electric Slide and you know
it that's that's the battle that's the
group battle but the Cabbage Patch was
the one in running man can be done soon
what about the Macarena
what's that the Macarena with or without
cheese
oh boy
oh yeah yeah
he's talking about the big Macarena
well I saw the Ragu and I was thinking
macaroni and cheese yes remember I just
drink my coffee out of it yeah why do we
have this Ragu here by the way I know
let's not call attention to it
it does fit but no I mean it's just uh
it's a colorful prop I don't know I
don't know how it got here I really
don't is there anything more the life
also is there anything than a jar
regular like I don't like Ragu well I
don't mind it but
do you still refer to as gravy or people
well I do but a lot of Italian people
don't hate that and call it
I call it gravy
you know why because of The Sopranos no
because gravy this I would call sauce
it's just tomato sauce but it's gravy
once it's on something no see I call it
gravy because when I make it you can't
make it without the meat and meat and
grit and gravy like gravy comes from
meat gravy is a byproduct of meat gravy
is brown and goes on like a turkey
there's white gravy yeah there's all
kinds of I mean I I'm colorblind but I I
only like brown grape I call brown gravy
this sounds like a a a a a a a slur
Ragu yeah
yeah like a Big Ragu yeah these two
ragus I was out walking my dog the other
night in the corner there was two
raccoons and uh I just I don't know
something about it I literally I just I
talked that they get sauce I didn't even
go yeah they were
you're so [__] good
come on I'm just You're the Inspiration
oh of course Chicago Peter Cetera when
he when he got there
I just don't want you get a flag yeah
sorry homosexual
I'm sorry
out of the garbage yeah
this is a little dry do you Ragu you
know what I mean like well where I do it
I'm sorry go ahead oh yes uh do you do
you drink at all or smoke weed ever
yes
um I don't smoke weed anymore because it
hurts my throat that's the only reason
but I love it and I take Edibles I have
some with me okay but you do get
inebriated I'd like to get high okay
okay that's interesting because you're I
really asking I'm not like doing a bit I
didn't understand you're such a sharp
guy and you're so fast no I'm very
serious and you're so fat and I'm like I
wonder if he doesn't put any illicit
substance ever into his body because and
that's why he's so sharp but it actually
comfortable you need to know that you do
get blasted on edibles but still yeah
Japanese knife yeah
expensive
I re I was really asking yeah
together do you feel that the weed might
like dull your edges or do you get super
power uh like listen I I'll have this
conversation
you know I I told my girlfriend last
night I I was a little high and we went
into a a bodega
say that a shop yeah and uh I just
I was doing my thing was it was it a
good thing or a bad thing we could we
could we could do an episode on that you
guys come on my podcast we debate is
Rick annoying or is he funny well this
is important what borough are you in uh
it was Jersey okay I don't know if
that's supposed your thing will be a lot
more tolerated in Jersey than let's say
no because it wasn't it wasn't a thing
that I threw at the wall it was curated
we all built it together okay we all
built it together we all built it
together all right and I I got the last
that I was supposed to get which was
they were they that that was great is
probably what they thought right and
then that was the end of it nothing
Magic
but the best it could be right sure and
I walked out and I thought like I'm
I thought
I had these thoughts I'll Express in a
second but then before I could even
finish it I realized I think about
myself the exact way my mom thinks about
me and I realized I grew up with my mom
saying Ricky you're so funny you're so
quick you're so Charming you're so kind
and I must have and I didn't realize
yesterday I must have been like
you know what Mom you're right
I will subscribe to this for the rest of
my life and I will believe this for the
rest of my life should happen that way
it happens in reverse and that's another
thing I thought and I thought that one
before just like
you know you could have fake confidence
or you know you could you could just be
unaware and think things that aren't the
case I I'm great but other people might
have that right but like to previously
told your this year this and like how
much work you have to do to
overcompensate for that now you think
about all the time how grateful I am
that like I was told
so then are you sure
you're boundaries differently about you
to me very differently I'll get her on
the phone right and see any of those
things now I think that's actually
really nice
do you think do you say anything your
mom used to say to you I I have a thing
that I hate that my mom was always was
it that you're adopted
that you don't know your place you
weren't really wanted yeah that comes
off no my mom always here because your
nickname is I disagree yeah
[Laughter]
I usually get picked up a lot as a kid
and my mom would go they're just jealous
and to this day if I think seven years
will like me in my head I go they're
just jealous
so when people you're in traffic like
hey [__] you're like jealous much do
you have one yeah yeah uh I don't know
um
my mom will tell you right away that I
spoke I put three words together
relatively early
like I spoke a sentence early she'll
tell you I learned to read early and
she'll tell you that I like jazz from an
early age that's the three things she'll
tell you that those are all very like
that's like what Kubrick would say
letting the receiver decide that you're
a genius ah you know how would you
describe Sal I mean he listened to Jazz
since he was one years old he must be a
genius right wait I don't understand the
quote though let the receiver what's
also happen all at one time uh I I'll
remember I'll go back sorry it also
happened all at one time yeah that's
even you're brilliant yeah I was playing
a jazz record and I walked up to it and
read the label and she was like and it
was the labels and listening to Jazz was
the label just three words yeah what was
it it was this is Jess
isolation
what does I don't think I understand
that so letting the letting the audience
or the receiver figure it out so instead
of the okay yeah you understand now I
think so guys summer is the best and
there's something fun going on pretty
much every weekend from barbecues pool
parties and family vacations camping
trips blah blah blah
for all those occasions I want to make
sure uh I've got great wine if they're
ready and that's why summer is actually
the perfect time to join the first Leaf
wine club now I love firstly because
they make it super easy to get
personalized wine boxes delivered on my
sketch and since you get to choose that
day your shipment comes you can go out
and you can have all your summer fun
without stressing about missing that
delivery to get started with first Leaf
all you do is you answer some quick
questions about your likes and dislikes
on the website and their expert team
will select a customized assortment of
world-class wines based on your
preferences personally I want all the
roses and white wines in in the summer
but they've also got terrific Reds and
sparkling wines I rock Rose in the
summer and I love a nice sansare if I'm
going to be eating fish or pasta I like
a white that's just me I love uh I love
a rose in the summer uh I'm a peanut
Joey Rose Joey Rose I am a Pinot Noir
guy mostly even in the summer I like it
like eating with dinner uh and I I enjoy
a nice cab uh and a Sauvignon what I
like about this is I can discover one
this way right now I'm usually limited
to the Wine Place the the liquor store
the wine store that I go to what's on
the shelves for me trying new stuff this
is different this is throws out a much
bigger net I agree it's kind of like
having a sommelier
let's send you some stuff which is
really nice anyway make sure you got the
great wine when you want it when you
need it this summer you got to try this
firstly folks head over to firstleaf.com
taste buds to sign up you get your first
six hand curated bottles for just
44.95 go to try firstleaf.com taste buds
that's
t-r-y-f-i-r-s-t-l-e-a-f.com slash
tastebuds to get your first six bottles
for under eight bucks a bottle try
firstleaf.com taste buds
folks game time game time game time I
love going to events I like going to
events without a big commitment in
advance I like making last minute
decisions when I want to go to events I
want to know I can get the best tickets
available at that time in that last
minute moment for the event that's why I
love game time that's the way game time
app does and I think a lot of people
fall right on the same uh scenario for
you you could buy tickets to your
favorite events last minute they
guarantee the prices you could see where
you're sitting directly from your seat
they have Flash Deals
um literally Comedy Sports uh you know
concerts they have every kind of thing
there's event cancellation protection
um there's just no reason not to try it
especially if you're looking for
something to do and a lot of times we
associate getting tickets oh we don't
have them the things tonight we can't go
not with game time also game time
guarantee they have a game time
guarantee that means you're going to get
the best price if you find tickets in
the same section in row for less money
game time will credit you 110 of that
differ difference so here's what I want
you to do I want you to snag those
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use taste buds that's the
code for twenty dollars off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account redeem the code taste buds for
twenty dollars off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed instead of saying instead of
saying you know it's really sunny out
right if instead I'm doing this while
we're talking
and then like
I missed something and the audience
realized oh he missed it because it was
sunny this whole [__] time if they
were inside everything would be
different like they get to be part of
discovering the thing it's why people
like inside jokes it's why people like
um it's why people like uh callbacks in
a way callbacks also were fun and they
make something that was spontaneous blah
blah blah but like they're in on
something instead of being told like um
like uh hey you gotta try this pizza
dude you're like maybe if you trust my
opinion but like if you try the pizza he
walked up to by you and you were like
yeah right that's a better example okay
that's a much better example if I said
you gotta try this pizza versus I just
come in with a pizza dude you know a
great example oh this is a good example
yeah you know what's crazy the themes
[Music]
this would be different if you guys have
headphones I want you to know that I
don't think people realize when you have
headphones you're able to hear the other
person better no he would he could have
said he'll still just talk over
everybody I don't know he my podcast
make the decision for yourself at the
end of this hour I hate wearing
headphones I won't wear it I hate them
to refuse the last thing I need is more
of you in mind you know what the problem
is you're uh no no listen listen you
guys I'm sorry guys sorry you cut you
off sorry I cut you off I
oh I have the best example ever of this
when Harry met let's hear that right
with the word from do you Ragu
When Harry Met Sally I'll have what
she's having when she orgasms there it
is
I was gonna say that I had this
conversation
Joe gets a slice thank you
I had this conversation last night uh
and uh it's apropos right now
um or did you just read the books what's
that apropos yeah is that the guy with
the raven
yes he's buried in Baltimore
big fan and I'm gonna quote him right
now
what we're talking about kids
see you don't like headphones because
you don't like wearing headphones it's
not about wearing the headphones
it's about being in the podcast oh I'm
in this thing okay I'm in this thing
nobody's more in this than well I
disagree
what is the greatest gift a parent could
give their child not it's I'll just so I
can so I could navigate this the right
way it's not something physical yeah
safety
love what I'm told and that this was the
conversation yesterday is autonomy
that's the greatest gift it's a great
gift literally free like freedom and
autonomy that's a great gift but but if
you could well if you're autonomous but
you don't feel safe what you choose to
do with yourself is going to be
surviving instead of living
like I don't mean like put us in a
basket and send us down the river but
they are like oh why did you say that
you have every single don't Rob the of
an experience by telling them what they
should do or should feel let them have
that experience let them form their
opinion unless let them learn that way
what else that teaches acceptance but
everything also has also everything also
has limits like some I don't believe in
helicopter parenting but I also don't
believe in I don't believe in autonomy
meaning like okay parents that are like
parents that are like let their kids
running around being like what the [__]
mom and you know it's like that's not
autonomy well that's not what I mean
that's allowing them to be disrespectful
they're still parenting autonomy is
here's have you seen as you've seen of
course do you remember the movie Big
Daddy oh yeah he lets he lets him choose
his name Frankenstein he lets him pick
out his albums
well okay I do that's kind of autonomy
but if he was going to a wedding the kid
couldn't be dressed in this big outfit
right but why not why not isn't that the
kid saying that's how I think you
dressed to show your love I hear you at
a wedding and I'll tell you I'll tell
you how okay
and I'll tell you how by stepping back
for a second tell you a motto of mine I
live my life in a quarter mile at a time
almost
it doesn't matter if you win by it
second
or a minute a win is a win okay that's
what he said I think okay but what I
would say is I like to do what I want
and with that I don't want to do what I
don't want but that's assuming it
doesn't necessarily affect other people
negatively example of course if I'm
coming in here and doing whatever I want
but I'm being disrespectful of the place
that's not okay
but I could choose to come here or not
to come here if somebody has a long
distance wedding and I don't want to go
to that I I I'm not gonna well that's
also okay hold on a second hold this
thought put a pin in this thought I want
to start the battle because this speaks
so much to adulthood and we're talking
about childhood ready here we go
yeah yeah hold on ready start two
b-a-t-t-l-e Buzz Wow first first guest
to know the chant and do it with us
listen
if I'm going to law school am I going to
watch suits first probably
you know who said like Mike Ross and I
gotta tell you if I go to buy a suit I
might go to law school first you never
know and you're going to like the way
you look guaranteed you know who said
that Chandler Bing was it no no dang it
what was that Men's Warehouse yeah uh
wait okay so what you just said what you
just said very interesting and it plays
into adulthood okay because this is
something that bothered me about that
book that came out the subtle amazing
piece the subtle art of not giving right
it was all about this there was a book
that came out called the subtle art of
not giving I know that so this book
comes out the orange book I don't know
yeah but it's this but it's this big I
haven't you know it was this big hit and
everybody loved it and
right
wow I heard it was a big hit and
everybody loved it and then what were
the other things
what could those have been if you what
you felt the need to say why what are we
supposed to fill in I'm just saying blah
blah yeah
goes along with it everybody talked
about it everybody chatted whatever I
have a specific experience okay so
here's my point I listened to the first
chapter of it that's so funny because
when you said the book I was thinking
would you listen to it yeah I listened
literally one chapter
I I just wasn't very interested in it
but I was curious much like friends you
should get to chapter four before you
critique the book The Books whole thing
is what you're saying do what you want
to do as long as you're not hurting
anybody else
fine fine but make sure you get the
camera switch I don't like the example
it gave and your example also I also
didn't necessarily care for like you
said about the wedding thing I'm shocked
but here's but here let me tell you why
let me tell you why all right I'm not
saying so you should go to the wedding I
understand that in certain circumstances
yes sure but part of being an adult is
saying I'm gonna do something I don't
want to do for the sake of another
person that I care about yeah that's
that but that then Works directly
against what that book preaches or at
least what I gathered from the little I
heard of it am I wrong no I bought the
book I read it please go ahead I bought
the book in the airport I read a few
chapters and it wasn't taking it was
just kind of like reiterating the title
to me and I was like I'm reading I feel
like I'm reading redundancy and I was
like maybe it's me and then I bought the
audiobook so this guy's got me for two
dips into the pot and then I listen to
the audiobook I never did it right I
mean I so I found the book annoying
because the woman who reads it you know
it's very like I didn't finish reading
it
I'd like to speak on this totally yeah I
like to speak on the wedding thing
huh I'd like to speak in the way you
think yeah please because
if you don't want to go
there's a reason you don't want to go do
you not want to go because I don't care
to I'll speak for myself do I not want
to go because I don't care to be there
it's not worth it to me or do I not want
to go because traveling takes a lot of
work and time and money but I would like
to support if it's that one yes you do
the things you don't want to do because
your intention is pure if you just go
because I don't want to I don't care to
support I'm obviously not that close to
this person well that's different but
but it's not because are you doing
something because you're supposed to
because well you're supposed to do
things for other people or you're doing
something because that's one of the
problems with adulthood well yeah that's
this is an adulthood issue but
this way you're with your girlfriend
right she says personal she says it
would mean the world to me
it would mean the world to me if once a
week when we we eat out every night if
if three of those meals uh could be in
vegan restaurants because that means
something to me and it just means a lot
to me that you show me that you're
willing to eat in a place even though
you love me and blah blah blah now what
is I mean sweetie
yeah I know I know let's let's let's
ring every bit out of this pit yeah
I'm starting to be teaming you now
plagiarizing you're plagiarizing uh Paul
Abdul
you could say very easily
I get nothing out of going to the vegan
hold on but don't if you want to ask a
question or you want to say something
don't give me multiple choice I'm not
giving you multiple choice then what can
I say I'm giving you a breakdown I'm
saying you could easily say you could
easily say I don't care about the vegan
restaurant there's no reason for me to
go there right I get no enjoyment out of
it that's a or right I could say B
in which one of those where you don't go
to the vegan restaurant are you doing
something that's that's not being
selfish I am going to adulthood is
confusing it is easy child I'm going to
take your point and remove all the
leading statements because I love it if
the girlfriend said hey let's do uh you
should do vegan three days a week my
feeling would be very different than if
she said hey Rick it would mean
something to me if we could do this
because then I'm doing it for her
because she's asking and she's telling
me a want and a need that's what I'm
saying so yes I could but her reasoning
for it because I want you to show me
I'm out
I'll do it not to show you that I'll do
it I'm not gonna go to the wedding to
prove to anybody anything I'm going to
go because you show me yes you did run
it back I said it would mean a lot to me
if if you could come and show me that
just because you don't eat vegan that's
your wedding are you doing the Macarena
or the Electric Slide
show me was poor show me the electric
slide
show me was poor word show me his poor
morning but let's let's get let's just
get to the broader argument of this but
if you care about the person you will
want to do for them
yeah but you can't if the person at the
wedding cared a lot it would be
different than if they gave me an
invitation I'm going to say five years I
care about a lot of people in my family
and a lot of friends awesome they have
many of them have had destination
weddings that cost a lot of money and
are a pain in the ass
I attracts am furious about it but I go
yeah it's your family they're we're
friends but there are people in that
that take the stance that you're saying
that would say you don't have to go you
don't have to that's the we're talking
about autonomy I'm not saying it
wouldn't be nice it's about to have to
it's about starting to resent your
relationships because they feel like
obligations sometimes it is important
you do have to I have to step forward to
see you you have to step forward to see
me and it's not that black and white
adulthood is a mental prison it is none
of this exists in childhood none of it
because I wake up I play I eat I
I don't
know I overthink everything it's to the
point of Oblivion that's crazy you do we
do yeah not you I
that is tagged that is tagged onto
adulthood immediately and it never goes
away and you gain more and more
responsibility granted do you have more
experiences yes in every facet yes but I
find myself when you keep doing all
these great things yes it's fantastic
yes you get to come all the time yes you
literally get to own arcades sure now so
now I said those 200 things now no no
but like I I as an adult I find myself
Longing To Be A Child again
when my life was not my universe was
smaller and more contained I was able to
enjoy moments and people I understand I
understand you're talking about a
paradoxical six paradoxical paradoxical
you just blew it dude uh whatever
whatever you just revealed you weren't
really alone how do you say Paradox is
an ad just say there's three dogs
pterodactyl like pterodactyl pterodactyl
you're dealing with just say three
documents uh old people are dinosaurs
not like children no here's the thing
why is it a pair of it's a paradox oh
God look at look at me what's the deal
one two it's really simple people are
really making a meal out of that it's a
pair of pent legs no it's a pant leg
and a pair of pants which includes the
leg legs is like the one in front of the
X it's assumed a pair of shoes too
what's interesting about Rick is Rick it
carries both sides of this argument he's
the adult side that can explain things
like an adult but then the child like
that's your attention span no matter
what you say what did you say God what
did you just say you're both sides of
the argument
what was the thing you just said that
you could explain like this let me see
that where goofers
yeah
let me say the Paradox thing let me say
the Paradox thing no you wouldn't go
back that's a good merch no hold on hold
on let me say the Paradox I'm not saying
eliminate your experiences I understand
watch the Kick the Can episode of The
Twilight Zone that's what the entire
episode's about it's about old people in
the last stage of their life in a home
where life has lost all luster and all
fun and whatever because they were so
busy doing things they didn't want to do
unlike a kid when an old man comes in in
the movie version It's please played by
Scatman Crothers in the original I don't
remember who plays him well but they're
gonna say one we need to know
an old man comes in and he says I can
teach you how to be young again and he
makes them children he makes them
children okay and they play Kick the Can
and that's how they transfer into kit
transform back okay and then in the
morning they become adults again okay
and he says if you want this I can give
it to you and all of them but one say I
can't do it all again even knowing what
I know now like I can't go back you said
if you could go back would you generally
do it all again I'm not talking about a
life I'm just talking about what is a
better you just said if you could go
back
you know what maybe he'll say he could
use a better choice of words you can
empathize with that what but what was
your question then you said if you
would you go back does that not mean and
be a kid again well I just explained I
don't mean live my whole life again I
just mean that despite everything I've
experienced as an adult
I think I was happier as a child but but
but again I'm still not understanding
you're saying if you were facing not
true but you're you're asking the
question you are missing you're in to be
understood and that's a problem with
adults he just gave you the argument
what did you hear what he said no he
didn't you know why no headphones that's
right I don't understand the question he
gave it to you on a are you allowed to
say silver platter anymore
on a silver platter he said I was
happier as a kid and then he said you
know what actually that's not true pivot
food the there are a lot of factors but
there's only one
creative you think you're going to be
their marketing I think I'm excited
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up faster
with flavorful and nutritious ready
meals delivered straight to your door
You're Gonna Save time you're going to
eat well and you're going to stay on
track reaching your goals I forgot my
factory meal today and I was Furious I
got mine it's a caramelized onion goat
cheese risotto and I can't wait to eat
it right after we're done with this I
use Factor all the time I say it comes
every Wednesday there are fresh made
they're not frozen they take two minutes
to heat up they have a wide array you
could pick your own you could you could
you know they could send you some they
have vegetarian meals keto meals and I
usually I love the smoothies and I
usually rock strawberry banana but this
week I got a variety pack and mango came
in it and we all know mango is one of my
favorite fruits it's not my favorite so
me and Factor I've been having a good
weekend all right yeah I love it they
help you stick with your Wellness goals
with premium ready to eat meals High
quality ingredients they let you stick
with your Wellness goals by having
premium ready to eat meals featuring
high quality ingredients you know
broccolini leeks asparagus there's 34
plus weekly restaurant quality options
like bruschetta shrimp risotto Green
Goddess chicken the steakhouse filet
mignon and again ready in two minutes 50
550 calories per serving around that
number or even less and you need an
extra boost to support your Wellness
goals this summer well you can try the
Protein Plus meals with 30 grams of
protein or more per serving I just love
every option it keeps you on track it
keeps you right head to factormeals.com
tastebuds50 you're going to use code
taste buds five zero to get 50 off
that's code 50 off that's amazing that's
code taste buds 5-0 at factor meals.com
tastebuds50 to get 50 off
Rosa here
from the taste buds podcast I have got a
big fall tour coming up big venues big
shows big fun Avenal New Jersey
September 16th Toronto Ontario September
21st through the 23rd November 11th
Philadelphia PA my hometown at the old
TLA oh classic November 17th Pittsburgh
PA bottle rocket Social Hall November
18th in Buffalo New York November 30th
Denver Colorado defense December 1st in
Phoenix December 3rd in Salt Lake City
and more dates are being added all the
time go to jodarosa.com for ticket and
venue information and ticket links I
want to see you out there please people
also guess what the album salsa windfall
artificial birth available everywhere on
August 1st and if you want to buy it you
can go buy it over at band camp it's
dropping August 1st on Bandcamp a little
early so you can buy it at a discounted
rate and then it hits all the Digital
streaming platforms on August 4th I know
you've been waiting for it I'm excited
about it I hope you are too salsa
windfall artificial birth hitting those
streets the first week of August right
in time for my birthday also if you're
in New York City please come to Joey
roses we're open seven days a week
starting at 11 30 a.m every day you love
those sandwiches you love those drinks
why don't you love them together Joey
roses joeyrosesnyc.com
if you're listening to this right now
and you are a natural I am here I'm
playing the opera house tonight with the
guys
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
tomorrow we will be in uh the Cambridge
Field House in Indianapolis and we're
rounding out Saturday at the stifle
theater in St Louis for two shows grab
those but I am back on tour after that
because I'm filming my special in
Chicago in December and we are going to
be at the Hartford Funny Bone the
Syracuse Funny Bone the Albany Funny
Bone all by September and then we're
hitting Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes bar
Pennsylvania Wilmington
Macon Georgia which I was corrected
about many times Savannah Athens Georgia
I'm coming through you Mount Pleasant uh
there you go and then Peoria Rockford
Cedar Rapids Springfield Illinois Duluth
Minnesota Appleton Wisconsin which just
went on sale so you get those tickets
the still good ones Rochester Davenport
and Elkhart Indiana they're all on sale
right now they're all going to be before
the end of this year
salvolcanoacomedy.com for tickets and
you know what check out some hey babe
and uh some taste buds merch on our
website we got some good merch so you
should go there if you're a fan and buy
something don't be okay but I'm still
asking I'm not getting attached to
semantics I'm asking the question I
don't understand what your question was
were you saying if you were faced with
the choice right in this moment of
becoming a child again would you or
wouldn't you what what is your question
no I'm not understanding just it was
phrased wrong Joe I'm not saying I'm not
saying like you become a child you give
up your life you gotta do it all over
again I'm just saying childhood versus
adulthood compartmentalize them a child
when were you happier is that in a
general sense I was happier as a child
there are a couple things that have
happened in my life that I wouldn't take
back you know but I'm not speaking in
those terms what name two well what
terms are you speaking a pair of things
okay my pants yes no listen to me listen
to me here's a deal okay yeah I'm I'm
not talking about like I'm not talking
about me I'm talking about the the idea
and the existence of childhood and
adults I'm not talking about me okay
it's all the wrong words everywhere in a
general sense in a general sense
the pressure very childlike of me to be
on the side of adulthood and look look
every time you're a child adults are
like quit acting like a child act like
an adult that's right you know what
that's why it's so children are like I I
treat me like it's always the greatest
no matter what Progressive new AG parent
advice podcast actually I'm not making a
bit no I'm gonna make a bit out okay
good but no matter what new AG podcast
or whatever
give your kids autonomy it is impossible
to give a child true autonomy you can't
you can't you can't give a child true
autonomy there will still be the
requirements and the discipline of you
go to bed at this time you eat it this
time you cannot eat Kit Kats for dinner
you cannot you know what I mean yeah but
that's not what they meant that's not
what they understand what they meant I
understand say run wild on a Hershey
Eminem I understand what they meant and
therein is the reason that being a child
will always star in more than being an
adult an adult I am 45 years old and
arguing with a child yeah yeah this is
what's happening every single thing like
an adult I'm telling you something every
single thing I wanted as a child that I
couldn't get because I didn't have any
money I buy it now any meal I want to
have that a parent would have said you
can't eat that right now I have it now
anytime I want to sleep I sleep anytime
I want to work I work anytime I want to
play I play I do what I want to do and
that is the basket case I'm not a
basketball I am too we all are I didn't
mean to slide on you I mean we are best
I have you have stress stress you have
pressure you have anxiety but you have
you're on this medication that
medication
I don't know I hear
I hear you but I'm saying I got news for
you most kids these days are on those
same medicines nope at our basket cases
I was depressed as a kid and I was
depressed as a kid because of the lack
of freedom of choice that depressed the
[__] out of me I hated where I lived I
didn't like it as a child all that goes
away hamster doesn't know what other
wheels are out in the world until it
experiences although you may not
it is it is no no yes you know that was
a sesame seed pun
[Music]
what I'm saying to you is is like I'll
give you an example okay I have a great
example for you I remember Christmas
morning uh when I was I believe 10 years
old what year were you born 77. okay so
this is 87. I got rocky three it was a
big it was a big uh it was a big GI Joe
Christmas that year my big present was
the um I got like the the [__]
hovercraft or some [__] the truck that
went into the water and it had depth
charges whatever it was called I got
that and a bunch of GI Joe guys and you
know and then my my aunts and uncles
came over and they gave us presents and
blah blah blah when was the last time I
got a GI Joe as an adult
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you think people don't give them to
me after shows you're wrong
uh anyway my point is is there were all
we opened all the toys we put everything
together we played with them for a
little while and I remember dude it was
like 5 P.M
December 31st the stuff had barely been
opened and played with and I said you
know your children are I I got sad and I
said I'm bored
and my aunt goes how could you be born
and I remember but I remember privileged
to be bored okay okay
childhood well then watch this podcast
hahaha
dude that's a Sesame Street as a child
as a child I'm still I'm still an adult
who is filled I mean over I'm 10 pounds
of wonderment in a five pound sack if
I'm being honest I am I I love
wonderment and I've tried to hold on to
wonderment okay but as a child
everything's wonderful you got it shows
are you being serious now a lot of
wonderment you my friend yeah thank you
thank you and you too well I do what I
can yeah so you know what I'm saying
like I have it too
stop the noise right yeah that's so cute
go like we acknowledge that we're just
talking about our wonderment he's like
buddy I have wonderment I get all struck
God that's so sweet I mean I saw Indiana
Jones twice to the theater I cried my
eyes
I get swept away but I hear you I hear
you so just shrink everything down
cancel the noise right put on headphones
okay shrink down your Universe becomes
exponentially smaller it's limited and
within those limits is freedom that you
cannot have when you do not have those
limits and as a child you're also
getting to experience everything all
over again the happiness I felt as a
child is way different than the
happiness as it registers now in in a
general sense I will say there is
something
I'm not doing that your palette wasn't
sophisticated yet but does but I think
there's Beauty in the Simplicity I
really there is there absolutely is but
if you cannot fully appreciate something
by definition it cannot be fully
appreciated if you've only can
appreciate it but you're talking with
the knowledge of it if I'm a child I
don't have that knowledge I'm still
satiated there's the rub which you won't
know anything about because you can
appreciate marinated flavors okay we
don't know what is out there and you're
saying you have a great life and we have
we don't know we know nothing but the
fact that we don't know what's out there
just as adults goes to show you that
there is still things to be discovered
so you can feel that way as a child of
course yeah and as an adult and I think
I here's here's what I think here's what
I think you I think and I can only speak
to my own experience as a child and an
adult I am wired almost identically now
to how I was addressed honestly I'm I'm
identical I was an Irate kid I was a
curmudgeony kid uh I was a bum I was a
kind of a Melancholy kid uh all good
merch yeah yeah I mean it's it's but
like all these all these adult traits
that aren't so uh uh Savory or whatever
I had them as a kid uh my excitement
about things as a kid carries over to
now the things I love and get
enthusiastic about now same as a kid I
laugh as much as I didn't think so what
do you think the feeling of not loving
Nostalgia is but here's you're longing
for the childhood I get it why is
everyone's favorite decade the decade I
get it but you could swap that you could
swap that with as a kid I was longing to
be old enough to be able to say I'm
going to live where I want to live
there's there's a there's a there's an
even trade there here's my point this is
the big difference I don't think people
are that much greatly wired that much
differently wired as adults than they
were as children sure life has thrown
difficult when they get older right and
there's a different level of Innocence
let me just get to this alternate point
the difference is and the difference why
adulthood will always be better is
adulthood lets you pick your spots and
childhood does not it doesn't especially
if God you've never seen Richie Rich
exactly especially God forbids the
Menace dude when you're a child how many
how many toxic relationships are you at
the mercy of as a child because you
don't have the authority to get away
from them a teacher a coach some friends
somebody in your family how about when
you get older you're literally you're
you're you're intertwined in a time but
you can but you can say this is toxic
I'm getting away from you you not only
have the palate to understand what your
needs are for example I don't want to go
to this wedding you also get to choose
your circles now granted depending on on
what type of employment you have in job
you have to check and check out but
still you get to choose your wife or
your husband or I'm not sure what the
other ones are now but whatever they are
yes you get to choose them I had a point
and I I have ADHD and so I lost it but
what I was saying was wait let me try to
get it back
um okay I also feel like I have many of
the traits I had as a kid right now I
even said I don't feel like an adult and
up here I still feel the feel I feel
like a kid okay how old how old yeah
what do you feel like because I feel
like I'm in my early 20s not a kid I
feel like I can pull from every bucket I
really do yeah I do I mean you know like
within I feel like I'm I feel like I I
have I am consistently 25.
sure but everything around you changes
the dynamic of your world your
relationship and your connections to
things and how you process season four
Once they got rich exactly when I was a
kid when I was when I was in grade
school okay when I was in grade school I
used to get terrorized
terrorized by this because you're an
Italian-American yes yes and we had
moved to Reseda in California and an
Asian man taught me karate
[Laughter]
wait wait but you could have you could
have boys but yeah of course
but hold on right and Bullies are real
in adulthood as well but here's the
thing I had a kid that physically and
emotionally terrorized me at my grades
what kind of things did he do uh dude he
I remember once he took a metal folding
chair like every wrestlers use yeah but
like a real one that's yeah steel like
well I think these real ones but I think
they might maybe have a little give to
they're also adults and they know how to
take a hit yeah yeah
he swung it now granted my grade school
was uh each class was like 20 some kids
there was nowhere to turn there was
nowhere to turn what do you mean there's
no other turn is 20 a lot
each grades each class in my grade
school was 20 some kids that's a school
small my graduating class in eighth
grade was 13 kids seven of them didn't
graduate yeah
so there was nowhere like there was
nowhere to hide you know every you you
were you were all together in in like
this very small space and this kid
remember one of the things he did was to
me he swung this metal he went like he
picked it up and he goes like that and
like brought it like within a centimeter
of my face and stopped and goes that's
what I want to do I want to bash your
[__] face in with this [__] chair
well dude I'm here I mean that kid's
home life was when you're 12. that is
the most horrifying thing I think I was
11. that you could ever experience I
would go home
you weren't to my mom
no it's 11 or 12. I know I went home to
my mom I literally would have breakdowns
like nervous breakdowns about it but my
point is there was anything here I
understand there's a point my point is
this you can't get out of that as a
child
the tuition's paid at the Catholic
school I'm stuck I can't transfer it's
May whatever the hell it is you're stuck
you got to deal with that every day you
go to the you go to the nun and go uh
excuse me Greg's picking on me she goes
you boys just get along with dismisses
it he finds out you told on him you're
gonna get it even the version of that in
the workplace look all I'm saying is but
you can
I know it's hard for all what's the guy
what's the kid's name first and last
be nice if you did this
for kids
here's my point that should be a podcast
that you have here's my boy yeah but
here's my pointing the kid
what's his name first and last dude
first and last what about his names
honest to goodness we get people
submitting names of bullies that
actually bully them and we get stories
of it and then we get the bullies on the
podcast they don't know what it is yet
we just say we're interviewing random
people right we get them on the podcast
and you don't assume they're bullied you
just ask them hey tell me the other side
feels hard to produce that's a great
idea I think they did that on like Maury
I'm not kidding I think they did that I
think we might need more of that because
I haven't seen that and then another
idea that I just got off the top of my
head inspired by that is we could bring
in uh couples here that have a kid uh
and then the guy doesn't know and then
he they could take a DNA test to see if
they did that on Jerry Springer you know
what I would like to do is find some
unruly 12 year old 13 year old 14 year
old girl and send them to boot camps now
we have a show all right that's good all
right
you can't get out of it as a kid as an
adult there are ways I know I'm not
saying it's easy I'm just saying you
have options to circumvent as a child
you are like that this is it dude I got
beat up by this kid Roger in my own bed
no one's ever been beat up by a Roger
but I know some Rogers that were tough
yeah Roger he beat me up in my own bag
you Google Roger in my own backyard you
know that's childhood okay honestly it's
hard to have this argument when we're
referencing your childhood
bro
what's the responsibility there is is
there is less who is he oh
got it
Roger bird actor I barely knew yeah yeah
wait a minute why did he follow you to
yard and beat you up what was it
yeah let's see above side
[Laughter]
I'll tell you something one of my
favorite books is Game of Thrones and I
have to say I love the the dad of what's
his name
what's the dad's name Roger no the dad
the drones yeah you know what's the last
name what's the last names not the
Lannisters the the Lannisters
no you're thinking of uh of Boogie
Nights
I didn't watch it Game of Thrones
targainian no not the targaryens
Lannister and the other people are
yelling the answer Lannisters
Lannister Nemesis who are The Game of
Thrones families type in type in type in
yeah type of Game of Thrones characters
just do that
Game of Thrones cast that'll be simple
so
yeah that start I I let the record show
that I knew that before it came up Ned
Stark I'll tell you something I could
tell this guy is going to be huge
throughout the entire series that was a
long walk for a joke
hey what I don't understand
I missed the entire did you see Game of
Thrones no
um
what was the joke uh there's well
spoiler alert there's a character who at
the end of the first season or one of
the books he is no more and I was making
a joke that since you've only read the
first chapters of all these books that
oh this guy he's gonna be there the
whole time okay and all the assumptions
that you make in your life from just
knowing one you know if I could make a
if I can I read most books all the way
through if I can if I can provide a
parallel if I can provide a parallel you
not choosing to be informed with the
rest of the chapters after one is very
similar to what you're seeing a child a
childhood is and that's it's funny
because you you're practicing it without
knowing well I was starting to say this
earlier the reason I didn't continue on
with the book was not only did the
sentiment not grab me the woman reading
it what I found to be very annoying
uh that's a whole other bag what is your
relationship with women very good I love
women
just not their voices
most the word Tendencies or the voting I
could do without outside of that I'm
good
you're like voting off the island sounds
like it sounds like you um have a
complicated relationship with Roger's
mom to answer to answer Pimp's question
why do you get beat up my back here
because it was just you know suburbs it
was a small group of kids like everybody
just hung out with everybody and this
kid was a dick he later we became
friends it actually became cool so is he
in the ditch with you why are you in are
you doing the [__] we're in the
backyard oh just your yard we're just in
the backyard and when how did it start
he just hit you in the face he he didn't
beat up his Too Short there he grabbed
my head and palmed it like a basketball
and started squeezing it like and
applying so much pressure
he was a very big kid he was a very big
kid almost like he got he wasn't like my
mom was like you're not allowed in her
house anymore she saw him do it and she
he was just a bully he was a bully kid
that like hung out with us and like got
away with it this is what I mean about
being a kid when it sucks he got away
with it because he would do it when
people turn their back and nobody ever
saw him they were talking about a broad
sense here
I mean look I mean I don't want you know
first they came for the for the for the
Jews and nobody said anything adults do
do it but as an adult as an adult you
can get in your car and drive away you
know what then you're a lucky adult okay
because there's a lot of people that
can't get away a child isn't going to
start a war I'm not saying there are you
you know what you're saying as an adult
not as a refugee for example
I'm not saying I'm not saying there
aren't adults that aren't in beds and
there's a lot of kids that don't get
beat up in their backyard all the time
I'm saying you've got an option as a
you've got far more of an option as an
adult to to get out of something you
don't have you don't have somebody all
the bad in the world is caused by adults
all of it
100 of it that kid bullied you because
his parents did a bad job with him you
know what I'm saying and it's just get
it and they're okay not about right it's
not about it's not about pain it's not
about evil it's not about bully it's not
about this it's about an option to
change your situation with immediacy as
an adult versus as a kid whether it's
but because that's a plus for you but
this is the hugest part I'm just talking
about broadly Broad in a broad sense a
kid is can be a happy-go-lucky he could
be bored he or she there's not an agenda
the agenda is to experience life and
educate yourself and it stops there play
and educate and that's it everyone is
loving oh buddy buddy as much as I love
being a kid and love love everything
you're saying yeah if you think that you
stop play and educating when you become
an adult that's the problem no you don't
and I agree
but what I'm saying is like it's so at
its purest voice
you're painting like a Domino's oh boy
go on yeah I love being around them
because they're so innocent and pure and
I love that officer I'm not an adult I
swear
I mean I said it that way to three of
them but
yeah
I was serving that up I saw you realize
what you said no I I was I was what's
that called when you're inside and
inside with Leo to carry against the
Inception the adult arrogance in the man
I knew
childhood I'll give you the benefit of
the death yeah no I'm not not I'm being
said serious that's why I'm giving it to
you okay so you're painting a you're
painting a Donna Reed sitcom version of
any references you're painting a you're
painting it you're painting in All My
Sons write down a child's day on paper
and write down an adult sandpaper in a
general sense the child is just I'm
longing for the Simplicity but you could
choose that as an adult yeah no I don't
think you can even yes you could look at
my shorts these were 500 yeah but you
have really I stole them okay great okay
now look at earning money
I stole them from work I went to work
they paid me
I bought you know why I saw these shorts
and you know what I didn't do mommy can
I have these shorts and my mom goes not
now honey we have to you know Daddy the
restaurant is closed and things are
tough right now I went I went I looked
at the shorts and then I took them and I
went to the cashier and I said mommy can
I have these shorts put it on my car
[__] all right yeah that's great did
you piss your pants
I mean I mean Summer's off I mean but so
I've been off for a decade Sal I know
you're you're uh yeah what yours this is
work what you're saying about what
you're saying about you want to play
over and sell ads what you're saying
what you're saying about uh like when
you made the the thing when you made the
joke about my childhood well when it's
your childhood it's kind of hard to do
it whatever
you're doing the same thing with your
adulthood though you're describing your
adult life in in in stop it's not my
adult life with adulthood comes Stress
and Anxiety pressure and responsibility
what that's that's from Spider-Man right
what I'm saying though is your Stress
and Anxiety as a kid you have depression
as a kid all those things are there as a
kid but the agenda is there as a kid we
got to do this we gotta do this we gotta
do this you don't talk to them they're
not cool he's a nerd he doesn't get to
hang out with us that person you're
saying the same thing for adults we have
to go to this wedding we have to do that
we have to do this no no no I can't I
just I just want to pull back a little
I'm saying the very simple statement of
as a child you have less responsibility
less stress and less or people around
your universe is smaller and I think
within those confines is something that
is very very appealing despite I could
make a list of pro so he's just talking
right he's just talking the pros sure
you're just saying pros of being a child
you're not negating that this pros of an
adult go on on my on my my my worst
problem as a child the worst worst
problem in okay
in a general sense a child's worse
problem that is not in a war-torn
country day-to-day
child uh their worst problem you know
it's not even you wouldn't suck them off
in the bathroom whatever it may be
everyone's different but when you get
this it's not even close you can't even
have the conversation so this is this is
why my argument is different I remember
I got an ulcer I got an [__] boss I
got a kid that won't listen to me I got
a promiscuous daughter I got into a car
accident I gotta call the insurance
company 12.
this is why childhood sucks I know I I
just remember from such a young these
are these are all true statements I
remember Roger squeezed my head it's
different yeah Roger squeezed my hand
Roger squeezed
you know what when you get older the
world is Roger yeah all right fair
enough do you know what I mean but the
world is Roger but here's what where's
Roger in here
omniscient here's what I will say here's
what I'll say we got to wrap up but
here's what I would say
staring at an early age from a very
early age I remember when I was in I'm
not I swear to God I'm not exaggerating
I'm not saying anything
that's in third or fourth grade I
remember being annoyed squeezed my head
this is so funny it's such a funny
t-shirt
what is this 1984.
I remember knowing what dating was
knowing that I liked the idea of women
like or or girls whatever at a young age
and being so frustrated that I was and
going to school and seeing the eighth
graders like boyfriend and girlfriend in
the playground stuff and being so
annoyed like I have to wait years and
you're still you still have to do it
about three more years and I'm gonna be
able to do it no but I was like I I have
to wait years to experience that I hate
this I remember on the this is not
exaggeration I remember the first day of
grade school in third grade waking up
and going to myself I can't believe I
have to do another year of this I can't
believe it's gonna be another seven
years before I get to [__] yeah
but y'all
butchers whatever I
have money to buy the comic books I
wanted to buy or the toys I wanted to I
know I'm saying it's it's hard using you
you in this example right mostly you
don't feel like most kids let me
rephrase it like this
to make you happy when you're younger is
so low yeah
you have the best day in the world if
you if you got ice cream okay sure I
would need to hit the Mega Millions
right now to recreate that happening
what is the last time you had ice cream
but last week how was it fine I didn't
even need to have it I know okay and
that's real and you talked about this we
talked about this on the road we talked
about this on the road and here's where
I will see you really here's where
here's where I would I see you last
night that you would have thought I I'm
surprised I didn't come yeah really
there's a place there's a place in New
Jersey and I'll tell you after I get
weird about telling spots near where I
yeah dwell have sex but I'm telling you
something I was a little stoned I got in
this place the cookies are good we're
all over a little Stone last night
you're going to bodegas we went to
dinner and then then I once they wanted
to go to this cookie place and then we
walked home and we passed by the thing
the cookie place
they just they're always making the
cookies every week or two weeks there's
new flavors they had something that I'm
surprised they don't have often
chocolate chip
I ate this I ate I ate this you're
already only listeners want people to
understand this because I'm gonna show
you my my reaction I ate this cookie and
this is what I felt
hey yeah it's a great feeling
I've had great children blown off I've
had great chocolate chocolate chip
cookies before doesn't mean that
yeah but it was unbelievable but you
have to find that one you know which one
makes you feel that way as a kid the
first one that's handed to you do you
understand what I'm saying your bar is a
lot lower if you left me alone just
right now I would literally have an
anxiety attack if you left me alone my
thoughts as a kid Star Wars figures are
gonna fight GI Joes and that's but so so
you what I hear you but what you're
saying
right what you're saying to me yeah hold
on what you're saying to me and that's
what happens when you're alone
what you're saying to me about my
childhood Joe it's hard for you to use
your child to judge this argue it I'm
saying to you about your adulthood I
don't think every adult feels like if
you left me alone for five minutes I
would have an anxiety attack
no adults are left alone anymore thanks
to cell phones all right right I had
tons of fun and happiness in my
childhood I'm pointing out the parts of
it that I'm I'm gonna put at the
negatives because I'm arguing again I
would fist pump being able to stay up
for 15 minutes later all right Roger
okay
and that's that's that's a thing that
made me joyous yeah yeah I mean me too
made every kid Joyce sleepover
Paul McCartney your best friend Billy
can sleep over you're joyous yes uh uh
sleepover for an idea this way
podcasting I get this way of podcasting
with friends yeah I get that way I get
that way when I go I'm I'm at my
girlfriend's place and I know she she
wants she's tired she wants to go to bed
and then she goes I think I want
something to eat and then it's like wait
a minute are we ordering something not
only are we getting food now but also I
know we have another hour we're staying
I gotta be honest that the surprise
ordering delivery really will rev my
engine
we're getting we're getting tacos right
now do you want to should we get like do
you want to get tiramisu or something
we're already getting it that feels like
a kid except for now I don't have to ask
my mom I don't know I I don't think that
could be distilled down to that exact
emotion I think it's okay
hold on wait wait
I didn't see
the priest thing where's the wait all of
these were responded just now yeah yeah
okay guys I didn't have any creepy
priests tell me to sit on their lap in
my adulthood so I think I'll go with
that I watched my toddler laugh at the
most benign things and no I will never
experience that type of true Joy ever
again it's impossible as an adult do me
a favor do you agree with that keep that
one there respond to that person please
and say then you should check out the
take your shoes off podcast okay
[Music]
that is first of all first of all that
is not correct
you're witnessing a child laugh at
something because they are experiencing
it for the first time in their news
that's wonderful okay I'm not saying
it's not wonderful you're telling me
you've never sat at a table with a bunch
of comics and laughed harder than you've
ever left in your life to the point
where tears are coming out of your eyes
sure I would need a professional comic
uh
you're using him as an example saying
let's not use your life you're talking
we have some of the funniest friends in
the world right okay I watch my friend
Brian once when he was on crutches and I
was 18 when this happened so that's
technically an adult right
uh try to walk through mud the crutches
got stuck in the mud and he fell over
how are you 18 yeah I mean you can't
tattoo your abortion okay go ahead he
fell over in the mud and was screaming
at us as we laughed at him and it's the
hardest I ever laughed my stomach hurt I
almost threw up from laughing it was one
of the funniest obviously I've never
seen Bill Burr at Red Rock it was what
my point is is to say I watch my toddler
and it's Wonder it's it's your door
doesn't know anything that's what's
great that's what you're missing that's
what I'm saying no but he's saying
Through The Eyes of the top what he's
basically what he's saying is hear me
out please
going back to the hamster wheel yeah a
hamster doesn't realize it doesn't get
to eat sushi so it is loving this wheel
but what he is saying is you enjoy your
wheel hamster now that I've been let out
of the cage I love this cucumber wrap
and the truth is and I don't want to
blow your podcast up but the truth is
there's pros and cons to both and the
best case scenario is as an adult try to
live your life as free as you can with
autonomy without stepping on anyone's
toes and that way if you want to go to
the wedding you will and if you don't
you could stay in you could order some
cookies you could your girlfriend or
have her suck your dick or play with
your [__] or something and just live
your life as a kid in this adult body my
name's Rick Glassman I'm ready for a
place and I gotta say that and I gotta
say that that was like when Jerry
Springer wraps up it was great it was
great and I gotta say right now for
every sponsor for every moment for every
moment of child wonderment of
I'm going to tell you why I'm rolling my
eyes because it's another parent talking
about the miracle of their child okay
you're you find it wondrous because
you're watching something that's not
true that's not true
there we have this he didn't have this
and now he's he he of course he doesn't
want somebody to look at their child and
feel that way because
adopted you didn't have it
and you know what
you get to pick your mom now
come here and we're your moms
no overall though
I am Because You Loved Me and I'm sorry
that you didn't grow up with someone
loving you that way I did oh then what
are you being such a curmudgeon about
it
finish him I Am Shane I'm sure I'm
saying the I the the she didn't say
she didn't say or this person didn't say
I watch children she said I watch my
child I think it's an unfair I'll say I
watch children I think it should you did
it again I think it's an unfair bias
that you're putting on something and for
every CH that's where the eye roll came
from but this is what I was going to say
children are more innocent it's gonna be
something with it in case his wings
every for every for every time a child
can giggle let me please let me say this
God damn it for every child every time a
child let me just say this
for every child that laughs hysterically
for the first time they see a Smurf or
something oh my God the Wonder in that
an adult has an orgasm okay
an adult hits blackjack in Vegas that's
cool an adult goes to a concert and buys
the front row tickets their favorite
band uh addictions
you're talking about dopamine highs yes
as opposed to just wonderment yes you
don't think you can find wondering as an
adult that wasn't what I said a child
giggling is not wonderment a child's
giggling is a child expressing
insensitivity like Stanley Kubrick says
it's much more enjoyable for you to
discover it yourself and a lot of people
will say oh you're watching the office
for the first time I'm so jealous that
you get to experience it for the first
time but I would say as an adult I could
then create stories write my own things
the sixth lead I'm phenomenal
so many I come from I come from a family
that laughed a ton like like snort
laughing at holidays give us an example
crying was getting up and telling the
same story every year tell your skiing
story that we all love everybody because
it's like tell the story we all love you
know that kind of thing everybody
laughing hysterically I'm sorry I don't
find it crazy and wondrous that a child
laughs hysterically at something as an
adult I laugh oh you don't find it
wondrous because you are looking at it
as the adult it's not what you find the
kid to be it's the experience the kid
has correct it doesn't matter if you're
noble or if you are just as long as you
find yourself in a position to love and
to trust yes are you coming down on the
side of childhood I will never come down
on this no I mean are you voting I mean
you voting childhood I am saying that
childhood to you too unfortunately has
an age limit I am saying childhood is
this belief in in in in wonderment in
play you could try to recreate it as
best you can and you might do well with
it but you can never physically be had
the brain and the you can't you can't
recreate it that's all I'm saying you
can practice it and I agree because
that's what I do much like religion yeah
you could practice it but the fuel you
need to make you happy
to make you happy and and to make you uh
you know uh
feel comforted or feel satisfied it's so
little so much less I think people take
so little yeah you're saying less you're
you're you're glorifying by saying a
lower bar but another version of that is
saying a lower standard if you could
just walk around be like oh look at this
rock and enjoy it good for you but
you're not going to truly appreciate the
complex flavors of a Michelin restaurant
the love of a woman or a man who
comforts you in a moment of emotional
vulnerability
I actually have a great point no one
told me life was gonna be this great
point
I have a great Point wait hold on I
think somebody has a point you know why
a childish you know why a child finds
wonderment in a ladybug because he's
seen it for the first time I still find
him in later
let me finish one million first that's
that okay one million first and you know
what they are they're firsts and they're
all exhausted and the wondermen of those
are exhausted far below to the chocolate
chip cookie I had last night far before
you stopped being a child and if we were
able to continually discover things for
the first time as adults like you do for
a child seeing things we've never seen
before right you would be in the same
state of wonderment but you can't I mean
not and that's the thing you you could
if you put a lot of effort into it it's
not as easy
it's not as easy as seeing a ride I want
that I want to be but I want you to be
remember when you had that you were
three it goes away that has nothing to
do with the application you can't apply
that no because there were a few things
now there were a few times I was able to
have a friend like my mom convinced some
other kids mom to let the kid play over
okay and the kid would play over after
school and he didn't want to come over I
wanted to wrestle and I didn't realize
he didn't want to wrestle but I grew up
and get off my ass about it but the kid
I knew was coming over on the bus after
school okay now I experienced this once
twice three four times I had experienced
it the feeling I got when I was at
school all day and know that this kid
has a permission slip to come on my bus
to come over yeah was unbelievable sure
and now let me tell you something else
yesterday I knew I was coming on this
podcast
I was getting on my friend's bus
you're it's you're wondering that's the
wrap up take us to the vote bye here we
go I think childhood might take it I saw
a lot of comments as he was scrolling
yeah uh and it's not good that he's
putting clicking off
we got 7 000 votes
oh
oh you idiot
about this one that you don't get that
often
we didn't really sample the jury
properly because the percentage of this
that our adults thinking the grass was
greener then yeah if children that's why
I think we need to get more children to
follow you on social yeah yeah if
children reasons on social media [__] I
have to wait seven years to get my dick
yeah yeah they would be saying the other
way yeah yeah
the percentage
the percentage breakdown by the way when
you when you found the VHS that your
uncle had and and you put it in you know
that's also mind-blowing everything's in
11 everything the cookie the friend the
rock everything right now there's Ebbs
okay and 11 is literally it's a tough
one I think this is a lot of people
going I have a kid and I love my kid
this is adults voting this is adults
voting I think it's a lot of parents
voting in that respect you've probably
had skewed things I mean look but okay
is it it's 64 for those listening
childhood one 64 point five percent to
35.5 percent how much of that we can
tabulate what's the record you know this
is
that like the sample are people that are
just from one thing yeah yeah yeah all
right I tell you the truth I didn't know
who was going to win that before I saw
that Rick do a quick plug before we
everything you need babe yeah listen
um uh uh
uh what's your show called again this
one no taste buds the one with with
everybody's pranking of each other drink
Yankers yes Impractical Jokers we're
gonna be in uh Cincinnati yeah you're
gonna be in we're going to be in
Nashville Indianapolis and St Louis on
the 27th through the 29th of July
tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com thank you I
have a podcast called take your shoes
off I also have a new podcast with
Esther rovitsky called Rick and Esther
have a time
um but listen I feel like if if they
enjoyed me coming on here they know they
just they just go into Instagram or
whatever you type them so you do comedy
yeah I don't have a tour okay I don't
have a tour setup in fact I'm starting
I'm touring For the First Time end of
summer setting it up now well there you
go they need to know that but I don't
have anything set up yet so but they
know to wait for it the anticipation
it's like it'll be childlike listen if
there's really one thing to plug it
would be make yourself as happy as you
can while not getting in the way of
anybody else
I still love you babe love you too
is gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them